[Musica]
buonasera a tutti mi chiamo salvatore
aranzulla ho 27 anni e oggi vi
racconterò i passi che mi hanno portato
a diventare un divulgatore informatico è
un imprenditore digitale la mia storia
nasce in un piccolissimo paese della
sicilia
si chiama mirabella imbaccari è un paese
di mille abitanti
un po come le persone che sono qui oggi
in questo teatro un paese minuscolo nel
nel cuore della sicilia li all'età di 10
anni riuscì a convincere i genitori a
comprarmi il primo computer
mio cugino giuseppe mi prendeva sempre
in giro per cui aveva un computer mi
diceva guarda io ho un computer tu non
lo avrei mai tuoi genitori non te lo
compreranno mai fino a che ebbe un'idea
portare i miei genitori un negozio di
informatica in un paesino vicino
aggrappare il primo computer che vide
incominciare a piangere a strillare e
costanza ingenito era comprami con cui
computer
questo fu l'inizio della mia storia
tornammo a casa e casa vamo questo
oggetto né io né i miei genitori
sapevamo cosa farne sapevamo come
utilizzarlo è un oggetto che stava lì
che mi incuriosiva e non qualcosa di
nuovo
io nel frattempo avevo 10 anni andava a
scuola quindi torno a casa faceva i miei
compiti e la sera premere il bottone
accendeva il computer incominciava a
smanettare incominciavo a vedere con
utilizzarlo a come risolvere i problemi
che incontravo giorno dopo giorno
nel frattempo anche i miei amici
cominciano ad avere i loro primi
computer e cominciarono i sequestri di
persona di salute era una nulla avevano
un problema venivano a prendermi a casa
con la forza mi portavano come un pacco
a casa loro chiedendo in salvo sistema
mi questo problema e mi resi conto
subito di un qualcosa più persone
presentavano lo stesso problema più
amici mi ponevano la stessa domanda
da qui l'idea di risolvere il problema
solamente ad un mio amico di scrivere la
soluzione all'interno di un documento
word stamparla e dava di atri diventano
uno spacciatore di soluzioni manuali tra
tra i miei amici a scuola
distribuiva i compiti in classe ero
bravo ma distribuivo anche le soluzioni
per risolvere i problemi con
l'informatica il passo chiave è stato
all'età di 12 anni quando creai
aranzulla punto.it aranzulla punto.it
nasceva come un sito amatoriale un sito
nel quale pubblicare quei documenti quei
documenti word con le soluzioni che davo
ai miei amici ed ha gestito in maniera
amatoriale immaginato un ragazzino di 12
anni che accesso ad internet e che è da
piccolissimo paese della sicilia
pubblica dei contenuti
questi contenuti di metter su internet
figuratevi che non aveva la più pallida
idea di chi leggesse questi contenuti
fino a quando e di un'idea nel 2007
inserire in pagina un codice per vedere
quante persone leggevano i miei
contenuti
rimasi a bocca aperta 300 mila persone
al mese con sul tavolo il mio sito
internet per risolvere i loro problemi
un qualcosa che mi lasciò a bocca mi
lascia esterrefatto 300mila italiani e
consultavano le istruzioni scritte da me
nel tempo libero
nel frattempo stava per terminare gli
studi e io studiavo liceo scientifico di
piazza armerina un paese accanto al mio
in sicilia che dovevo scegliere quali
università fare la mia ambizione era
quella di studiare non tanto informatica
sono autodidatta sull'informatica quanto
piuttosto economia il mio sogno è
entrare in bocconi
i miei genitori non potevano permettersi
di pagare l'università la mia è una
famiglia modesta mia madre fanis mia
madre fa la casalinga mio padre fa
l'infermiere vedo tre fratelli giuseppe
e davide quindi avrebbero potuto
permettersi la possibilità di mandarmi a
studiare a milano
per caso scoprì l'esistenza di un
servizio chiamava e si chiama ancora
oggi google adsense è un servizio
semplicissimo avete un sito internet e
volete monetizzarlo volete guadagnarci
di scrivete su google adsense prendete
un codice lo mettete in pagina e da quel
momento in poi google per conto vostro
vende della pubblicità questa pubblicità
è legata ai contenuti del vostro sito
internet se pagate parlate di
informatica troverete pubblicità di
informatica
se parlate di motori probabilmente
troverete della pubblicità sulle auto
il primo mese in cassa il doppio dello
stipendio di mio padre un qualcosa
i primi soldi che appunto arrivarono
investito talmente nella mia istruzione
decisi fini di studiarli cioè
scientifico mi spostai finalmente a
vivere a milano e nel mio sogno
dal piccolo paese alla grande città
andavo all'università andava in bocconi
come i miei amici
seguivo le elezioni facevo studiava a
casa con l'unica differenza che il
weekend e e le note le passavo a
lavorare al sito internet tutto il tempo
che riusciva a ritagliarmi al di là
dello studio era dedicato al mio sito
internet l'anno 2008 2008 2009 gli anni
diciamo e quali mio city incomincio a
diventare un qualcosa di importante per
me era vitale per me che si tu
funzionasse perché senza quello non
riuscivo non avrei potuto permettermi di
studiare troppe cose diciamo sì a
cavallaro no e purtroppo fu costretto a
fermarmi scoprì di avere una malattia si
chiamava colite ulcerosa fu ricoverato
in ospedale un paio di mesi e fui
costretto a bloccare tutto da una parte
devo la bocconi che richiedeva una
presenza costante dell'auto dovevo
cercare di fatturare dovevo cercare di
mandare avanti il mio sito internet
impresa tutto si era fermato il mio sito
internet continuava ad essere eletto ma
non dà abbastanza persone da rendermi
sereno in ospedale bio un'idea
un'intuizione
perché non trovare quello che gli
italiani cercano sull'informatica sui
motori di ricerca
perché devo essere io ad inventare le
tracce da trattare sul mio sito internet
sviluppa in un sistema che esista ancora
oggi si chiama sistema dei titoli è una
tecnologia proprietaria che inventa i
all'età di 18 19 anni ed è un sistema
che analizza quello che voi cercate sui
motori di ricerca e mi consente di
vedere quali sono i problemi che gli
italiani hanno sull'informatica in
questo modo io i miei collaboratori
riusciamo a dare la risposta ai vostri
problemi
qualsiasi problema che voi cercate solo
informatica sul motore di ricerca
probabilmente finite su aranzulla
punto.it aranzulla punto.it e oggi è
diventata un'impresa tutti gli effetti
ho superato le difficoltà iniziali che
ho appunto avuto nella mia carriera di
imprenditore oggi ahrens uno.it e e tra
i trenta siti più visitati in italia
se prendete una classifica trovate
google trovate facebook trovate youtube
trovate una sfilza di siti porno e poi
trovate anche aranzulla punta e ti eri
soprattutto
quello che eri un altro dato
interessante è che ogni giorno 500 mila
italiani consulta nel mio sito per
trovare una soluzione
un numero impressionante ma quello che
mi emoziona di più non sono tanti numeri
non sono tanto le cifre i fatturati oggi
è quanto piuttosto l'entusiasmo delle
persone che mi fermano per strada per
ingraziarmi che è appunto hanno risolto
i loro problemi con informatica sono
anche le lettere le mail che ricevo
dalle persone io ricevo ancora spesso
delle lettere da persone anziane l'ho
ricevuta una circa un mese fa di un
signore di 85 anni che mi ringraziava
per perché seguendo una mia guida era
riuscito a installare skype sul proprio
computer e quindi a riuscire a vedere i
nipotini che si trovavano dall'altra
parte dell'italia queste sono grandi
soddisfazioni al di là delle cifre dei
numeri del appunto fatturati che è che
si possono appunto ottenere peraltro
stesso signore in questa lettera aveva
allegato 10 euro dicendo mi guarda non
smettere questo è quello che posto
importante che non smetti perché
altrimenti non so come sistemare il mio
computer in caso di problemi
ho cercato
pro cercato di oggi un po di e di
assumere la mia storia un po per tap le
tappe più importanti soprattutto per
dare uno stimolo ai miei coetanei io
vedo moltissime persone della mia età
che è appunto sono senza lavoro che non
sanno cosa fare
internet fornisce ad una grandissima
opportunità per trasformare quelle che
sono le proprie passioni in un lavoro
quindi fornisce delle opportunità anche
a quelle persone che magari sono in
cerca di un lavoro che magari possono
decidere di crearlo appunto da zero come
ho fatto un pò io partendo da un piccolo
paese della sicilia essendo diventato
quello che sono oggi
grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]